on this week's show how to build the
perfect property power team in the news
the property market is booming
despite brexit looming and we're gonna
be answering all your property related
questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends hi I'm Russell
EADS I'm Alistair Cunningham welcome to
this week's property investors podcast
we've got a brilliant show lined up have
you been my friend if you had a good
week yeah it's been pretty cool we've
been very busy again up and down to
London looking at not offices now
because we've got them secured but
looking at apartments things that are
yeah there's a few places of phone quite
interesting so like one of the places
look that's got concierge with an
on-site gym so I can help me lose a
little bit weight I can tell that you
you're a gym goer yeah what's favorite
machine the sauna
that's not machine it is you press a
button and it starts working yeah what's
the point right how did you leave me man
how are the schools schools amazing yeah
I'm in that tying up now whether to go
for state school or private school I've
never ever even because I'm not never
ever even considered private school
before but they're men in London when
you're looking at like that like every
other every other school is a private
yeah as there's laws where we're from
you just don't really get private school
so it's but then looking at it I know
I'm a big believer in education
obviously we've run an education company
and I'm sort of thinking it makes sense
to put them in the best environment yeah
possible and the right people and all
that sort of stuff is quite expensive
though how much it's normally like okay
I used to live near campbellton private
school which was it's a very good
private school in Cambridgeshire and
I believe it was like 7,000 pound of
town it was a lot yeah yeah this the one
I'm looking at is hi march in Beckett's
field so it will start because emily is
only in nursery so it's cheaper for her
about half the price so it will start
off this year it will cost about 18
grand just for her for the two but then
next year that will go up to about 22
and then by the time but but then when
they're because they're there in year
over year 1 and nurse at the moment by
tying them in year 6 it'll be about 30
grand for the two so it's expensive but
it's one of those isn't it's one of
those because when you look at the stats
it is better yeah I've never even
considered it before I've always I've
only even thought about it's just always
been state state says I'm just way not
really at the moment I don't know be
interesting to see what you guys think
it's private you know do you send
because not many people know private
school I suppose especially around here
but in London it's a much bigger thing
everyone does yeah there's a lot more
money in London for a start and then we
can afford to do it salaries are higher
everyone's gimli and would you ever
consider it private school for me no not
for you you [ __ ] as it was quite funny
I went and Emily was having a trot
heavenly was having a try it was having
a trial someone came up to me and said
are you here for the trial day and I was
so tempted to get I was just like yeah
but I was so tempted to make some sort
of sarcastic comment I'm not actually
she I don't know if they would take your
dry humor to be honest why London now in
the states to in this private school you
do humor sort of your humors you have
it's sort of chalk and cheese like you
know I mean yeah a lover you hate it and
you have to warm to it it's not just
something you do you can't just throw
out there yeah you have to tempt them in
a little bit but I do just throw it out
that's the problem when I'm mixing new
groups I just throw out there and people
I mean see your humor is so dry that I
never know if you're joking or if you're
being serious and I'm like did he being
serious a joke and you like I'm being
deadly serious we started that went into
a new church I'm gonna see a house crew
yes and it's like you know it's like 10
was 10 so people around and I'm like
making all these people just like after
after a few weeks they've thought oh
he's he's joking he's joking but at
first some of the Bellas you've come out
with before I'm like I think it's funny
when people I mean people on that listen
to the podcast and then they comment and
go oh I understand I understand what I
understand what they mean but anyway on
with the show so interesting topic
yes you met schools but yeah this is
interesting as well how to build your
perfect property parenting yeah it's so
important well first of all let's say
let's say who we would include in a
Power Team right so Michelangelo
Michelangelo yeah I don't remember the
rest of the ninja mutant Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles who are they all right
okay so who's that the rat oh they did
this all did the master okay right okay
so we need a solicitor yep need a
builder oh I've got a counter an expert
builder yeah mortgage broker mortgage
broker late an agent really yeah it's
pot your power team yes why don't you
well cuz okay fine
because you the idea of a power team is
suspense what you parties for well miss
Clara fry that first do you so for
example if your power to because if I'll
give you that agent let me give you look
the way we do it we teach people to find
an area
and dominate that area so let's just say
you pick on Blackburn okay so you go to
blackboard and you need you need a team
in that area that I prepared to serve
that area for you
so obviously mortgage broke on
accounting can be anywhere in the
country and solicitor can be anywhere in
the country doesn't matter but in the
area you're gonna want a good Lane agent
I'm giving whether it be single let's
hate you more and you're also gonna want
a good build team and a good handyman
that's what you would ask three main
things you're gonna want in that area um
do you know the quickest and easiest way
to build a power team in an area you
wouldn't have to find one of them people
I don't know and then you've got the
rest do you know when it is learn engine
yeah Lane agent you find a good let an
agent so they should see it this is
called heat Jamal because that's what we
do before we do is anyone else
so it's sister accountant builder
mortgage broker letting agent it's just
a cabin build um always broken let
anyone else I would say that's that's
probably bad yeah I would always have a
handyman as well but that could fall
under the Builder yeah because you want
somebody that's not quite the same rate
as our if you've just got like for
instance one of my hate chores we just
have to change like some light bulbs and
we just have to change a lamp shade
because it got broken and things are so
I'm not gonna pay a builder couldn't do
that when I can just pay a handyman 30
quid to go and do that so I would always
have trying to have like a handyman on
one hand you're my handyman yeah like
what I fix your car Leah um someday like
just for instance it could be somebody
you just know an area like an something
it's sort of may be retired or so much
to do and just get get maybe a podcast
partner or something and then just ask
them to do odd jobs yeah pretty much see
dry humor don't know if he's been
serious or not but like for instance the
problem of got mover Hampton they the
guy took the property from he had a
handyman and his name is Jay and like
whenever his name is dryer down Jeff
thanks Jeff yeah and then literally if I
need anything doing I just say Jeff can
you go and do that why'd you say Jeff I
was his name so I'll bring up Jeff
can you go and do this and he was like
yeah no problem I'll do it but he's not
quick it'll take him make three days so
for instance I had and what cuz that
cool anything
it's like Jeff neon build me a house in
three days bang in it you know I mean
bang it up like but a handyman wouldn't
be building the house so I'm talking
about building a house fast so isn't
rope yeah I'm sure Jeff doesn't do this
right how do right there's new Starbucks
where we are yeah I know how they built
it so quickly it's a fab called prefab
innit yeah it's all prefab and it
probably wasn't a matter of days it's
just it appeared to be amount is
probably weeks but it's all
prefabricated weeks a matter of days no
it's math 21 days right fine but it's
all prefab so the building will get
brought to them in sections and they'll
just bolt it all together they don't
build do you know I mean it's all prefab
that's how they can do it all quickly
and it's all built in a warehouse before
even comes to the thing you need to all
together and they have a team they'll
probably do proper finders 50 people
there on site doing it I don't care how
many I'm just like how come it's taking
us like a year to refurb rivers foot
house and takes them like two-week build
a whole building and every without is
20,000 square feet in stuff that's why
they're and rumors over has half fallen
down and they're not if reverse was gone
and they had to start again and it would
be a lot farther on by now the minute
they're trying to I know really why but
I'm just amazed at how fast they can put
it up well yeah it's very very good
slow Jeff right I had a ordered a new
fridge for the property and I said to
Jeff work I've got a fridge getting
delivered on Thursday can you make sure
your property to just take delivery of
it no problem he charged me 10 pound
just to unset in my property all morning
wait for the rigidity to get delivered
same and Wi-Fi when the Wi-Fi got
delivered you have to do it so I would
always want a Jeff in the area cuz don't
and like you have to be cool it can be
whatever he wants to be called but I
call him Jeff cuz that's his name yeah
and you know a good place to find them
it's on like Jeff calm Jeff talked
Facebook because you always find sad old
lonely men but nothing to do you on
Facebook
you're on fire today you're on fire
right so you need a Jeff and your Layton
agent find a good let an agent and they
will have all these people maybe not a
Jeff but they'll have all these people
so they probably will have a Jeff yeah
because that they use people like Jeff
don't Lee yeah to be fair right
it's Lister your accountant and your
mortgage broker mm-hmm that can be nice
you know there have to be in the area
the only ones that need to be in the
area even builder to a degree doesn't
have to be in the area no you want them
close by like for instance my I've got
builders and Doncaster sorry bill
doesn't whole but they'll cover
Doncaster Liverpool they'll cover all
that within the hundred miles and
they'll just go and stay in the house
that they're working at but they won't
come down to Bristol for instance and
well painters and decorators that are
engine builders are much more expensive
in certain areas yeah for example would
you not just pay Doncaster builder to
come down here I'll give you a grand yep
travel well cuz my friends since my
painters and decorators that were in
Hull that charged me not a lot of money
they do a phenomenal job by the way
don't think just because they're cheap
that they're crap didn't know didn't
hold on last week and you can quote Nick
could you pan hold on Nick I want you to
play this section right only to play
them because the quote side by side she
can okay I he said last week I've always
been taught about you pay cheaply pay
twice and then you just said what did
you just say now I said they're cheap
but what mean is that cheaper than the
going rate so for instance which is well
you just hate what you see what you just
said like latest based estate London
right you're not going to get a
tradesman for lesson two hundred-pound
250 penalty and up nor can get him for a
hundred penalty they're not doing any
better job but it's just the cost of
living and the cost of location so
that's what I mean when the cheaper the
cheaper than London so it's like you're
right so if you've got like for instance
um this starts there right now no no no
so for instance I had a property and
Northampton painted and I got my
decorators from whole to come down do it
that I put them up in a hotel for four
nights paid them their going rate and it
was still half-baked cannot let them
live in the property I'm not like a
complete Savage
that's what better source do with Ryan
and and Adam when they're when they're
so when we've got people have been
furniture we just tell us sleep on the
floor they make the bed in them oh well
but enemy like officer when you're
painters and decorators are there the
house is empty there's generally no
carpets done it's quite a cold house
because obvious it's very beer and but I
get them to go wherever and I pay them
like literally I pay their fuel costs to
go there and back I give them twenty
pounds a day for food and I put them up
in a hotel at their time and the time
obviously but the time don't mean the
time at all
but the time for traveling you just
cover that fuel just cover the fuel it
takes two hours to get there for our
round trip people don't so ok until the
exactly exactly what happened when they
come to Northampton go on the left hole
Monday morning came to Northampton they
spent four days in Northampton paint in
this house went home on the Thursday
evening I paid for three nights in the
hotel Monday Tuesday Wednesday gave him
twenty pound each pair Paris until those
three of them so sixty pound extra day
so 60 60 60 64 days 60 pound extra so
it's two hundred and forty quid they
charged me for the whole house they
charged me twelve hundred pound to paint
the whole house how much would that cost
so you got to pay me right it's down
right then right so you pay twelve
hundred pound for the job so the labor
was twelve hundred to 44 through 44 like
food subsidies subsidies you put forward
up in hotels food food and drink I know
I know what is it sub site it's not
substance of Sciences where the hey yeah
it's substance right fine yeah 244 I
gave them 20 pounds for like mules and
drink air and then hotel how much the
hotel cost yeah it was like a whole deal
I was like 60 70 pound eight pound per
person
no not one roommate three beds put there
for them oh they're three the three
those three of them so how much it cost
well for non let's just say there was
hmmm example to quit for three nights
Monday night Tuesday night Wednesday
night they went home Thursday I got 300
quid so 300 what else and then I bought
the pain ampule
yeah they get like 50 quid for fuel fish
beautiful fuel cover their fuel so like
50 so you spend 1200 Cal Q later mate
that's not hard
I was about to 179 oh yeah how much
would it cost if you have you got in the
pin in there no all right so that the
paint was 350 so at 350 that's gonna be
difficult now so 18 for a three pound 50
yep so it's 21 40 yeah alright I was
quite a 3 grand for that job so you say
I was quoted 3,000 pound Brian
Northampton builder and Northampton peon
dick were a team minimum 300 pal and
that's the 3000 pound and I still had to
supply the paint with the 3000 pound I
was quoted she served about 1200 and
yeah so with the paint with it with a
quote I was given by the Northampton
builders that that didn't include pain
that included all the filler and all
they're like poor so in other words then
wherever you are you better off going
and finding a building team in Hull and
just paint them to come down and if
they're prepared to do it so my painters
and decorators will go anywhere in the
country from as long as I pay their fuel
hotel and give them money for food
that's good yes
and I keep getting people on Facebook
saying you can't get that done guess
what guys I do all the time everyone on
Facebook say you can't get a hose
painting for 1,700 quid because you get
those guys thank you baby plus froze
right you see me plaster is man you get
a plaster off from up north to come down
that do just as good a job but they're
considerably cheaper what's the what's
the sweet place I mean like you know
like like it's all up north
anyone orth because listen sheffield
build yeah build teams down south are
generally quite busy so if you want a
decent builded you've generally got a
bit of a wait okay so my old my dad's
been in the trade for like 50 years
so and
he's always said if you ring a builder
up and they're available that week their
ship builder they shouldn't be
they bleep sorry yeah beep sorry if you
bring a bit of Ewing a builder or paint
daiquiri about any tradesman and they
can say yeah I'll be there tomorrow or
the next day
that gem lien probably like good most
tradesmen of their Diaries fill for
weeks and it maybe they get a
cancellation that's fine but generally
most good tradesman they're busy for
week so you have to book them in advance
if you've got a builder that says yeah
we've got a team they can crack calm
about tomorrow I would be asking
questions and I would be certainly
didn't read for questions we won't see
what their works like because generally
if there's no I would be one and be
asking them what their works like as
they say good will ask and they write
asking them for references asking them
for previous clients asking to uncie
some previous work I would be asked yes
he was very whole well yeah if I'm in
hollowed 10 max look at Houseman all
right just you've got to do you a better
DD on these people there's a lot of who
keep builders out there and the guys I
use I'm not going to give him away but
I'm not going to tell you who they are
because then everyone we call on them
and I want them for me and they do a
very good job a very good job and they
do they're very popular because they're
so good and they're so affordable
they're very busy you can find a lot of
them um if you go on places like yell
calm and see the ones that have got like
no reviews and things like that
another place to look as my build on do
you know what my builder comm there it's
like an online forum for this sauce
Geoff calm but the builders rather than
you go you know you could probably find
the Geoff doc what are Jeff on Jeff Don
Geoff calm you can probably know Jay for
my builder book comps I'm wondering what
Geoff calm actually is now I mean like
we're recommending this it could be a
porn site for a we now it's like if I
google it Geoff calm if it's porn I'll
probably and you're saved saved searches
I've never been on Geoff calm I can
assure you Geoff calm is a blog it's not
actually that interest I wonder if he's
going to get lots of views now anything
is it Jeff with it with a J or G hot
no I've got his mobile number I don't
know him that much I didn't wake him up
and say hey it's Alistair from pageantry
can you go and look at his eyes with me
anyway right that's how you do look at
find a builder do your research don't be
afraid of asking your builders to travel
my build a minute my build my build team
are doing three conversions in Liverpool
and they're from Hull they work on you
could build again to travel accountant
can be anywhere anywhere accountants
similar would you I would say a lot less
you want to go from recommendation so
networking is a good way of finding them
networking events and speak to property
investors see their use in saving it
recommendations to seek a solicitor
account and you build a mortgage broker
the same mortgage will again very very
much from recommendations yeah and and
be very strict with them tell them what
you want upfront and be the mortgage
broker in particular cards on the table
face up don't build [ __ ] them because
all you're gonna do beep beep sorry
don't BS them because all that's gonna
do is delay it's gonna delay the process
so if you've got a credit card you're
trying to hide from them because you
don't want the bank knowing just tell
them everything
don't lie to them don't try and hide
anything just be completely transparent
completely honest about your finances
your bank things everything and in that
way that they're going to help you the
best yeah and it's gonna it's not gonna
it's gonna avoid any delays because I
know people that have gone through the
process and they've not been a hundred
cent transparent with their outgoings
and for instance and then they've got
two months into it and then they've been
declined because they sort of told a few
pork is about the route going to begin
with and it just it meant the chain fell
through and it's just caused more
problems and swath
all right letting age is a bit different
I had found a good let an engine then
again depends single that hate you more
salacious calls to mm-hm all I would be
looking for recommendations
look on spare rooms see what letting
agents are actually renting rooms out
and see what what they're listing have a
look at their listing see if it's our
listing that you would perhaps if you
were looking would you be a drawn to it
and it is the listing good as it thora
is it accurate and the photographs good
is the properties that they're looking
after in good condition or are they all
rundown
go in and see them sit down with them
how helpful are they are the answer in
the phone when you call and do the
answer the phone can you get hold of
them by email by phone or whatever
would you would you say any tips for
keeping these guys because obviously
that this team is quite you know quite
an important team do you any tips on
keeping them sweet
yeah bribery bribery no I would just
listen for example like what what what a
little tip I think is don't all even if
you don't always nail them on price
never you know what you're like you know
the people that you've got you've got
you customers who know and you just like
get bored doing with them know
so my build are right when we we call
them up we just say look there's the
house you know what we want go in and
give me a price
we've never handled that price never had
with it and when he comes back to us and
says look our study
like for instance prime example yeah we
had to have a fire door installed
between a kitchen and I sort of a
hallway it's got an old traditional
slidy door but they took that off enact
a fire does that put a new frame on and
now when it took the old frame off it
pulled some tiles off the wall so they
can either budget all back together or
they can do it properly and they said to
me look it's gonna cost like three
hundred and seventy quid to do the
tiling and they're back in the kitchen
can we have permission and do that and I
of course I'm gonna give him permission
but don't hassle them don't like kick
off because they've come back and said
look they pulled the few tiles off the
wall the towers were obviously loose it
wasn't they didn't go in there my
screwdriver and rank them off the wall
they were obviously loose and they just
came off and as part of the process of
removing the door frame yeah so don't
don't don't be that person that says
well you quoted this it's 20 pound more
so I said I'm not paying it they'll
never deal were you again and to be
honest if you done that to me yeah I
wouldn't even entertain taking your
phone calls just treat me with respect
and mmmm it's the people business is it
people business people you can always
you know send them Christmas cards but
if you want to build whatever it is you
know give them a gift when they would do
a good job it bought this games every
every em like we had a property in
Doncaster my build team done that and
the property was completed on time it
went a little bit over budget because
there were some things come up like the
tail and that was a tailoring on that
house it was a few other things come up
but they Donna is cost of
as possible and when when we when it
finished I personally went to the
property to see it sign match was there
but I also went to see it and sign off
have a look at it and that took them
like creates a beer and things just to
thank them for their and you can also if
you notice if they have some stuff to
save money you can thank them can't yeah
it's got really appreciate the way
you've done that you know that's you
save me a bit of money there and even
let's just say let's just see the final
invoice comes in at seven and a half
grand and you're happy with that job
what's to see you can't just give me
another 500 quid and just bang on our
500 quid on top just see Luke thanks
very much you've save us some money and
just you've come in at you've come in on
budget I'm gonna give you a change it's
all about incentivizing and getting name
so when you form them they're like as
Alistair he's a good guy well that's
Russell he's a good guys jokes are
rubbish but he's a good guy
hmm that's funny
but that's what I mean that's what I
mean just you want it so that when you
ring they're picking the phone up and
they want to work with you otherwise
it's difficult how it teams are easy I
think but if you've got a good power
team all my days what I think it makes
makes everything so easy so if you can
get these five people in place man one
tip before we move on with builder yeah
you want to find a builder that has has
builders working for him you don't want
to be ringing all different trades so my
builder does everything it's just his
project management as well it's project
management so he does if it needs
plumbing he's got he's got a plumber
he's got a roofer he's got a Tyler he's
got a window man he's got a doorman he's
got everything and so you don't want to
be using all different trades because
then it gets very expensive so like you
don't want an individual plumber and
then do individual gas engineering arts
or stuff one guy that looks after
everything your project manager for you
and he'll look after them how do you
tell if they're a good builder or a bad
builder just look at their work ask for
reviews look online Google the name I
would always Google the name personally
and business and seafood got any like
outstanding county court judgment sort
of stuff a bad build and mock just do
some DD basic due diligence me the first
thing make sure he's good at going like
this you're the first year of builder
school
like and scratching their gonads a good
builders bum helps as well if like that
I don't like that but it shows they've
been on they've been around for a while
and if you've got if they come in with
coffee and doughnut your first Alastair
good builders boom always helps yeah
anyway it's now time for this
[Music]
in the news this week we're talking
about the property market is booming
despite brexit looming good title in it
it's great so listen it's on the Express
of the elite Express and the Hedden is
the property market is booming here
despite brexit figures reveal so Brix it
has led to uncertainty in the property
markets with house prices set to decline
even further however the demand for
houses and certain ehre seems to be
going up where are there Mario's oh do
you have an idea I am gonna guess
[Music]
Germany no the UK oh no okay so because
obviously a UK based so we're about in
the UK do you think property prices are
going up a respective bricks it harder
now let's guess by my guessing like the
street the county just village the name
of a city Manchester right good
no you're wrong right a place again then
okay crew no Doncaster no Birmingham no
and you Europe I mean if you were alone
a game show you'd be right our lives by
no no right with breaks at lumen house
prices are booming
no with breaks at lumen house prices are
protected today boy what is going on
with this section I don't know
listen listen listen so with bricks at
lumen right house prices are predicted
to decline even further the uncertainty
in the housing market just reading it
again it's like you've just read this
you don't ask me to guess telling me to
read it again we have to do that very we
have to do it again right okay Frank I'm
not saving you out of this okay so new
research has revealed that certain areas
are experiencing an increase in buyers
snapping up property and the highest
level of buyer activity taking place in
yeah Glasgow and Edinburgh well in
Scotland yeah
the latest demand index by sping
Springboks properties based on the ratio
of home sold to those for sale across
the UK and the nation's most popular
towns and cities showed that buyers
demand has crept up slightly in a second
quarter of year one by 1.8% when you say
is booming right this is their hard code
it was no 42.3% up over the UK across
the UK how much forty two point three
across the whole yes so what I said
Manchester I was right then was my no
well you should across the whole of the
UK so Glasgow and Edinburgh they're
getting forty two point three percent
increase across the UK yeah
what's not that is it's just in girls oh
no it's across the whole of the UK so
it's not just classic whenever is a so
easy man chest there's snapping
properties up so there's more sales in
the Glasgow Edinburgh correct with you
the places are named let's not on here
but Manchester is booming so I was
correct but it's not on here so this
article doesn't make me into Manchester
so as far as I'm concerned you're wrong
but basically what it says if you're in
class go to Edinburgh House players are
sale and faster than anywhere else and
they're sailing for good money as well
okay so which is this interesting
considering in Scotland fascinating Zuma
Scotland what disdain they want to stay
in the EU so imagery of Scotland anyway
but they're not have no idea MIT we
stayed in EU
and we're gonna be at break so what's
happening with our lanai what's up in
the UK now that we've cleared that up
and they all know exactly what we're
talking about it's now time for this
[Music]
it's now time for questions and answers
first one on my Instagram from Adrienne
I believe hi they're tuning in all the
way from Australia that's pretty cool
should we do the whole the whole g'day
there on here g'day there it says it's a
goodie you know it's what they say man
no it's just our neighbours okay
Alf from neighbours loving the podcast I
can't wait to come back and join the
crash course in September I know you
guys have mentioned some areas in the UK
which becoming saturated edge Myers my
question is do you think that UK
property investment in general will
become saturated in the near future
no because such a brilliant place to
invest currently no good question it's a
very good question I hate us I think we
kind of present seen it yet but probably
calculated bit last week in they are
protecting it from becoming
oversaturated no I think the UK's a
great place to invest phenomenal and I
think it's only going to get more and
more and more better but obviously
they're going to run out of land
eventually if they keep building houses
but you're talking thousands of years
away
you're not talking an entertainment
regeneration I'm great thank you it
Blair's actually really good question so
I've got a question here for from
Brandon Baker on property investors of
Simon Leeds group and it's hey guys is
there a list or a one direct source you
can go to find article for areas which
have been covered or is it a matter of
session of every council website just
wondering if there's a more efficient
way and we were talking with this last
week on last week's episode
unfortunately there's not one place list
so Brandon seems like there's a gap in
the market there for you so you should
create something and then sell it so
hopefully you can do something that I've
got another question from Tomas Tristar
hey guys I've just read in the comment
that it can take months to get your anti
money laundering to set up source and
company my question is can you sell
deals before you're getting your AML or
have to wait for it once you've set it
up you'll be issued with a number you
cannot trade until you've been given
that number
it can take up to three months it took
me six weeks but just keep hassle on
them
I know anti-money laundering
registrations taking a little bit longer
and then before but you can trade once
you get that number you don't have to
you don't actually have to appear on the
register because sometimes they do other
register yeah sometimes see what I mean
about is dry humor sometimes yeah we
know what you mean we know what you need
you are compliant you're talking about
other things
Oh hold on you thought I was talking
over things and you said yes okay okay
so when you apply for a ml M it may take
a couple weeks and you get issued a
number some what happens is it does take
three three to six months to appear on
the anti money laundering
register once you're on there then it's
public domain but you can trade with
I've been in the public domain because
you are registered if you've got your
number give him a call see what the same
but that's that's my understanding of it
okay so this is from CG CJ brewer come
on
would you recommend doing the buyer e4b
finance model if you was gonna be re C
he really should do the bird strategy
shoot actually ago okay would you do it
if you're doing using a credit card for
the refurbishment so if he's using a
credit card to do the refurbishment
would you do it by reefer be finance
so he's I'm assuming he's got the money
for a deposit cash but he's not about
the money for the Denney reefer walk and
he's planning on using a credit card to
pay for the reefer but it could it's
just using other people's money it's
just being creative yeah good thing
about credit cards is you can get you
can lump all your credit card debt
together can't you can get like 0% so
you actually can use credit cards if you
as long as you pay it off yeah well you
did say in brackets don't worry I'll be
able to pay it off when he gets the
money out so that's fine that's good
yeah that's good but so one more
question and this is from Tara Maria we
met her at the crash course in
Birmingham to be bombing a motorcycle
museum I'm sure it was two weeks ago
I only briefly came to that okay you
know our member terraces me several
times of yeah
I did and then I spoke the second day
and Tara was very complimentary so thank
you I've been seeing a lot of
information flying around regarding
mortgage companies putting up their
minimum boron amounts for limited
companies at the crash course we looked
at houses around forty to fifty thousand
pound mark do these changes make these
houses are unmarketable on mortgageable
and does this make buying property as a
sole trader more appealing love the
podcast keep up the good work so what is
the minimum mortgage rate it's about
four - it's about four - yeah some
mortgage some mortgage companies are
seen as higher in a limited company so I
know some are seen seventy five thousand
again find a mortgage company they will
lay in forty thousand pound on a limited
company that's just about getting a
broker isn't it very good broker and
then there is you might be like okay no
for that UE my my better sole trader but
there's some out there that they have
their own terms and conditions known
rules to what they work to but I would
find a whole of market independent
broker direction so if you perfect no I
don't so guys thank you ever so much for
tuning in don't forget we're back next
Saturday at 7 p.m. we would love to see
you there
you can check us out on Spotify Apple
podcasts as well t watching this on
YouTube and we will see you next week
see you later guys
[Applause]
Oh